un autre focus du jour nous conduit
aujourd'hui en Afghanistan un pays aux
mains des talibans qui a faim selon
l'ONU la quasi totalité des Afghans
vivent aujourd'hui en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté dans ce contexte un
phénomène est en train de prendre de
l'ampleur la vente d'enfants mineurs de
nombreuses familles les pouces à se
marier à marier à leur fille parfois
très jeunes à des hommes bien plus âgés
une association lutte aujourd'hui contre
ces mariages forcés et ces trafics
d'enfants voyez ce reportage signé
Dorothée olyrique Élodie Delevoy et
mortaza à beboudi
Amina 10 ans est sauvée et ce sont des
larmes de soulagement elle avait été
vendue 2500 dollars par ses parents à un
homme de 15 ans son aîné mais le mariage
forcé n'aura pas lieu la famille est
emmenée par une association loin du camp
de misère où elle vivait
pour Amina un saut dans l'inconnu après
4 heures de route elle découvre la
grande ville des rates
nous l'avions rencontré dans la province
reculée de badris au milieu des
montagnes il y a trois mois dans le camp
pas de taliban nid d'ONG mais des femmes
et des enfants qui tentaient de survivre
la seule richesse c'était les petites
filles et beaucoup étaient à vendre
est-ce que tu sais quand tu vas partir
et comment tu te sens
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez honte quand vous la
voyez pleurer comme ça de l'avoir vendu
c'est parce que nos enfants meurent de
faim je n'ai pas d'autre choix
aujourd'hui Amina et sa famille ont été
relogées c'est son père qui nous
accueille
nous retrouvons la petite afghane avec
émotion comment vas-tu
tu vas bien
je suis contente je me suis fait des
amis mais je ne connais pas encore leur
nom
la petite fille est fière de nous
montrer ses cahiers pour l'école
[Musique]
oui c'est moi et Amina va pouvoir rester
avec vous il y a plus de mariage
on est content que le mariage soit
annulé et qu'on soit ici
tous ensemble
je suis heureuse d'être avec ma mère
aujourd'hui grâce aux aides reçues la
famille peut rêver à un meilleur futur
un changement de vie grâce à
l'association to young toed trop jeune
pour se marier
sachez qu'on va faire le maximum pour
vous
avec ses collègues Aziz tawacoli a
réussi à faire annuler le mariage ce
sont eux qui ont sorti la famille du
camp
est-ce que cela a été très difficile de
sauver cette famille
pour les détails le responsable de
l'association nous emmène au salon pour
parler discrètement
ça s'est passé sous la supervision des
imams de leur quartier pour annuler le
mariage on a dû promettre d'aider le
père à trouver un travail on a signé un
document écrit ou le père s'engage a
rembourser l'argent au mari d'ici un an
ou deux
pas question pour l'association de
racheté Ramina ou une autre petite fille
cela pourrait pousser d'autres familles
à vendre leurs enfants
dans le camp où vivait Amina nous avions
rencontré une autre famille un cas de
figure très différent Sabera 4 ans avait
été vendu 500 dollars par sa mère un
couple qui ne pouvait pas avoir
d'enfants
même si je sais que personne ne doit
préparer une mère de son enfant comment
j'ai pu donner une petite fille comme
elle
tous mes enfants allaient mourir de faim
aujourd'hui la fillette a retrouvé
définitivement son foyer grâce à
l'association l'adoption a été annulée
Sabera va à l'école à Irak pour la toute
première fois
salut mes jolies
univers totalement inconnue pour la
petite fille afghan Sabera et mal à
l'aise
qu'importe la musique et la maîtresse
bienveillante elle ne restera dans cette
classe maternelle pas plus d'un quart
d'heure
elle n'a pas dit un mot
dans les régions les plus pauvres et
reculées d'Afghanistan vendre des filles
très jeunes c'est une coutume et plus
jamais vous allez vendre votre fille
non je ne la vendrai plus jamais
j'aime beaucoup ma fille j'ai été obligé
de la vendre et je n'ai pas arrêté de
pleurer
depuis l'arrivée des talibans on estime
que la vente des petites filles a été
multipliée par trois une pratique
pourtant officiellement dénoncée par les
talibans mais pour des familles peu
éduquées c'est parfois le seul moyen de
survivre
allez on poursuit par direct avec
l'actualité sportive le journal des
sports et notamment la Ligue des
Champions avec la victoire de
l'Olympique de Marseille face au
Sporting Portugal regardez